ici on recevait jouer de la musique ou
dispensés de l'éducation l'appartement
du dauphin était un lieu d'effervescence
le 1er avril il retrouvera le public
fermé depuis plusieurs années il se
visitait sur l'inscription sa
réouverture permettra de voir tout le
rez-de-chaussée appartements du dauphin
ce temps les plus importants du château
donc ce n'est pas un petit événement
c'est un grand appartement d'apparat qui
se situe en rez-de-jardin qui a une vue
extraordinaire sur le parterre d'eau et
sur le parterre de l'orangerie et
parterre du midi donc c'est un endroit
crucial qui était hors de la vue du
public depuis de longues années un
appartement composé de quatre pièces la
chambre le grand cabinet la bibliothèque
et le cabinet de retraite de la dauphine
le grand cabinet a demandé plus de sept
mille heures de travail notamment pour
redonner de la superbe aux boiseries
dans la chambre c'était de trouver le
ton juste pourrait accorder les dorures
ancien que nous voulions préserver et de
trouver le ton de fond parce que la
chambre nous a donné si vous voulez la
justesse un peu le diapason de
l'appartement
ici des difficultés c'est la
reconstitution des sites rumeau les deux
grands trumeau et puis les quatre
trumeau d'entre eux fenêtres et puis
l'ensemble de la dorure qui a été
complètement repensée et justement
ajusté à partir de la chambre deux ans
de travaux pour se rapprocher au plus
près de l'aménagement proposé pour le
fils aîné du roi louis 15 jusque dans
leurs pubs le mans une restauration
permise grâce au soutien de deux mécènes